[Hank Green]: Good morning, John!
[Casey Neisat]: What really blew me away
is the sense of community,
the sense of excitement;
all of this energy that's surrounding
this event!
[Alli Speed]: Seeing
how YouTube changes.
[Connor Franta]: The first VidCon I ever went to,
I was a viewer;
so, I watched things like this,
but I w- and I was right in there.
[Felicia Day]: Video, to me, is a way to make people feel like they belong.
[Kevin Alloca]: You are, basically,
the early pioneers of the new and different medium.
[Franchesca Ramsey]: I wasn't seeing
people like me represented
in television.
[Katie Couric]: This is my first, uh, VidCon;
and I..
feel
very old.
["Come Out To Play" by Pomplamoose plays]
[Hank Green]: VidCon 2016,
the 7th
Annual
VidCon,
is gonna be a thing.
June 23rd to the 25th, in Anaheim;
and registration is available now!..
Because VidCon 2015 went pretty well,
we're basically going to be doing the same thing that we did last year,
just with a little more!
We'll have more stages,
we'll have more space,
we'll have more special guests...
Our goal with VidCon has always been to reflect the
state of online video.
And thus, as online video has grown,
so has VidCon.
But(!),
one thing that we haven't been particularly good in reflecting,
I feel like,
is the explosion in gaming content;
and I feel bad about that!!
Because streamers,
and YouTube gamers,
are huge!!
It's a huge thing,
and I feel like we just haven't been good
at- at inviting that in
and making it a priority at VidCon;
so, I really want to do that this year.
In order to make sure that I do, like, at least an okay job of that;
I have just been trying to understand the YouTube gaming world.
And the Twitch world, as well..
It so
diverse!!
It's so huge!
If a few people watching
want to suggest any gamers to me,
or any interesting things in the gaming world that I should check out,
please do that
in the comments!
I'll be looking.
Most things that will be pretty much the same:
we have the same tracks;
the Creator Track,
the Community Track,
and the Industry Track;
and the signings and photos
will be taken in the same way that they were last year,
with a lottery,
where you rank your favourite creators,
and then, based on your preferences
and availability,
you get some signings.
And that way, you don't have to wait in line for hours and hours!
And, I know that some people
do want to wait in line for hours and hours,
but..
first-come, first-serve is how we did it in 2014,
and that..
turned out..
[Laughing] kinda bad!
Other,
completely unrelated to VidCon, news:
the Project For Awesome
is gonna be on December 11th and 12th;
so, if you want to make a Project For Awesome video,
you've gotta start thinking about it.
If you don't know what the Project For Awesome is;
we will be talking more about it
during
Pizzamas!
If you don't know what
Pizzamas
is;
I'm about to tell you.
We celebrate Pizzamas
here on the VlogBrothers channel;
and last year,
we celebrated that
with two weeks
of Brotherhood 2.0-style videos,
which means
a video every weekday from one of us,
Hank or John.
Starting Monday,
there will be a video every weekday
for two weeks(!),
and it will be great!!
In addition to that,
we do a bunch
of Limited Edition
Pizza John shirts.
This is one from
last year!
You will not be able to get it this year;
but, you will be able to get a number of very cool ones
that I will not show you
until Pizzamas begins.
Which, it will,
on Monday,
with my video!
And then, John,
I will see you on Tuesday.